thank you
good evening everyone uh welcome to this
meeting of the standards committee
especially to our newer members of the
committee i will now read out the
emergency evacuation announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the entry doors to the
media block and continue straight on the
right hand side
of the car park where the assembly point
is
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded please switch off any
mobiles or turn them to xylem
members you will see microphones are
provided for you on the tables for use
during the meeting
when i invite you to speak please ensure
that there is a microphone in front of
you before speaking
as microphones are needed for the
hearing loop and for the audio recording
where possible please help by passing
microphones to each other and use the
hand gel and antibacterial wipes on the
tables if you do touch the microphones
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with constitution
i will ask for a show of hands for and
against
the recommendations and then for those
wishing to abstain from voting
so agenda item number one
tonight apologies for absence
um we have apologies from councillor
mrs mandy cohen has anybody else
any other apologies
no
thank you
we have no substitute members
gender item number three
agenda item number three non-members
attending we have no
other members attending apart from the
committee members but we do have a guest
we have mr steve summers who's the
strategic director
agenda item number four
minutes of the meeting held on the 29th
of march 2022.
um understandably this is more for those
members who were on the committee last
year are the minutes agreed members
agreed
thank you
gender item number five are there any
declarations of interest
there's none
um of course if any come up during the
course of the evening please just raise
your hand and say so gender item number
six
the new local government association
model code of conduct
members our monitoring officer angela
law will present this report
thank you chairman um this reports to
present to the committee the new local
government association moral code of
conduct
with the view to making a recommendation
to the council to adopt and replace the
council's existing code under part five
of our constitution
this new code of conduct comes following
a report made by the committee on
standards in public life
and
it was approved
back in may 2021 um various monitoring
officers up and down the country
have been in contact with lga clarifying
certain parts and i think at this stage
with the essex other essex monitoring
officers
we are at a stage where we are happy
with the final code the latest version
of the code to be adopted
most of the um
essex monitoring officers have either
adopted or are in the process of
adopting the code including brentwood
our strategic partner
i'm not going to read the report
verbatim members but i'm happy to take
any questions you may have
members are there any questions
counselor mr myers
having read the report and then read the
um local government ethics ethical
standards report
i say it describes the uh
um
code of conduct as a toothless tiger
is is it possible for the council to
bring its own sanctions in
no um that's governed by the localism
that so we we can't bring our own
sanctions in however however uh
recommendations and sanctions um
yeah is discussed with the relevant
group leaders to sit to see what's the
appropriate you know sanctions to be
placed where a councillor has been found
to be in breach but there's no
powers for myself or the council to say
remove anyone from a committee or or or
indeed um
suspend them as a member
expect the only thing you can ever be
removed for basically he's going to
prison for three months isn't it apart
from that well if you go to prison for
three months you'll no longer be a
counsellor
are there any other questions
members
right um well i've got a question
um
angela on page 6.10 which is uh page 4.6
of the new code
um he talks around bullying harassment
and discrimination um my question really
is um
how does this fit in if it does at all
with indirect bullying or harassment
um
i'll give an example many many of the
councillors here quite familiar with
social media and unfortunately
at times there are both harassment and
bullying not necessarily
by a counsellor
but on occasions
a derogative
post or message against the councillor
has actually been liked by another
councillor so would that be included as
indirect bullying or harassment and
would it be under the code
the answer is quite potentially
could be under the code any retweets any
liking of post where um it you know
brings the council's reputation or
indeed the group's reputation into
disrepute i mean that can all be caught
under the code but it really depends on
each
single case and how it and the context
of it all
so it's a potential yes thank you
has anybody any other questions
okay um
i'd like to say a few words on the new
code
so with the new code of conduct being
written in the first person
is hope the councillors will take a
stronger more personal approach to
ensure their actions meet those expected
of a councillor
it aims to build on the seven principles
of public life which we all know as the
nolan principles they are selflessness
integrity
objectivity accountability
openness
honesty and leadership
the new code
now includes the definition of respect
also the term bullying
is a new addition to the code i will
draw your attention to page 6.10 of the
report 4.6 of the new code of conduct
respect means politeness and courtesy in
behavior speech and the written word
debate and having different views are
all part of a healthy democracy as a
counselor you can express challenge
criticize and disagree with views ideas
opinions and policies
in a robust but civil manner
you should not however subject
individuals groups of people or
organizations to personal attack
then goes on under bullying
the code refers to the advisory
conciliation arbitation service acas
and characteristics of bullying as
offensive intimidating malicious or
insulting behavior
an abuse or misuse of power through
means that undermine humiliate
denigrate or injure the recipient
bullying might be a regular pattern of
behavior or one-off incident
it could happen face-to-face on social
media in emails or phone calls
happen in the workplace
or at work
social events and may not always be
obvious or noticed by others
of course in politics
many may come from polar positions in
life
being respectful to each other can close
divisions it can enhance cooperation and
build collaboration
each and every councillor should be able
to undertake their role
without fear of being bullied or
ridiculed
in essence
through mutual politeness respect and
kindness
we will aid debate
listen better to each other and work
more collaboratively to serve our
residents
with this in mind
i would like to add a further
recommendation
that leaders of all parties collectively
pledge to uphold the new code of conduct
within their parties and members
in addition to encourage any candidates
and campaigners to embrace the nolan
principles
do i have a
secondary i'd like to second that please
thank you councillor
mike wilkinson his second bet
yep may we have a vote in that please
members
if you're in favor please raise your
hand
so
to that
further recommendation
and i will repeat it again
the leaders of all parties collectively
pledge to uphold the new code of conduct
within their parties and members
in addition to encourage any candidates
and campaigners to embrace the nolan
principles
those in favor is
those against please members
and those abstaining
one
thank you
gentlemen
um
so members there is uh now
the recommendation that is on
paragraph 9.1 on page 6.5 of the report
that the
council adopts the ldga model code of
conduct
with effect from first of august 2022 a
set out in appendix one
and the additional
recommendation
that leaders of all parties collectively
pledge to uphold the new code of conduct
within their parties and members
in addition to encourage any candidates
and campaigners to embrace the nolan
principles may we take those on block
members
if you'd like to vote in favor
for
those against
none those abstaining please
that is carrie thank you very much
members
and the meeting
is now closed at 1943.
thank you very much for coming out this
evening members thank you